[موسيقى]
هذا ما تبدو عليه شركة بمليارات الدولارات
مثل هذا المطبخ حيث
يتم إعداد حوالي 40 علامة تجارية في
نفس الوقت الذي يقوم فيه فريق واحد بالطهي عبر
علامات تجارية متعددة ،
هذا ليس مطبخك العادي ، إنه
مرفق عالي التقنية مليء
بأحدث-  كل المعدات الفنية لجعل
الطهي أكثر كفاءة
، يطلق عليه اسم المطبخ السحابي وهو
ينتمي إلى شركة kotopi ، وهي شركة تقنية ناشئة في
دبي تنتج الطعام فقط للتوصيل إلى المنازل ،
وهذا هو المنتج الذي
سنبدأ في القيام به  ابدأ في
أتمتة لفائف السوشي على هذا ،
فبدلاً من محمد بلوط ،
أسس سلمان داركان الشركة في عام 2018
بهدف تسريع عملية توصيل الطعام ،
وما زلت أتذكر ذلك ، لذا فإن المطبخين الأولين
ونظرت إليه في
وقت ما  من 50 إلى 100 طلب كان يرتجف
ويتعطل بالطرق
التي تعرف أن مو سينظر إليها وسيبدو وكأنه
لا سيقوم بألف طلب
قريبًا جدًا ،
والآن أصبح لدى kotobi 75 مطبخًا تعمل في
جميع أنحاء المنطقة  مع بدء تشغيل 300 شركة
أخرى في الأشهر المقبلة
، وصلت الشركة الناشئة لتوها إلى معلم رئيسي
لا يمكن للقلة أن تدعي
أنها حصلت على لقب يونيكورن ، وهو اسم
مخصص للشركات التي تقدر قيمتها بأكثر من
مليار دولار
[موسيقى] ،
وأعتقد أنه عندما تحقق
نجاحًا بهذا الحجم  إنها علامة كبيرة
على الثقة في المنطقة الفعلية
التي ستبدأ هذه العملية
الآن ، حسنًا
، تصدرت عناوين الصحف عناوين الصحف عندما
حصلوا على 415 مليون دولار في
آخر جولة لجمع التبرعات مما جعلهم
أسرع شركة على الإطلاق تصل إلى تقييم مليار
دولار في
المنطقة في اللحظة التي ترفع فيها رأس مال بهذا
النوع من الحجم ، إنه أمر رائع ، إنه شعور
بالتواضع الشديد ، ومن نواح كثيرة هناك
إحساس مطلق بالمسؤولية الذي
تعلم أنه يتعين عليك القيام به الآن
لإيصال الكثير من الناس يسألونني أنك تشعر بالارتياح
بعد  سأخبرك أنه كان
بعيدًا عن الشعور بالراحة ، يجب
عليك التحرك بسرعة كبيرة ، وعليك تنفيذها الآن
على مستوى أكبر بكثير ، وعليك أن تبدأ في
التعقيد من أجل الكثير  تتطلع قاعدة
rger الآن إلى مجموعة قليلة جدًا من mo sam
وموظفيها البالغ عددهم 3000 موظف يتطلعون إلى
توسيع نطاق وصولهم إلى جنوب شرق آسيا
بدعم قوي من المستثمرين والكثير
من الأموال في البنك
، مو و sam واثقون من أن kotopi
ستستمر في تقديم آنا ستيوارت cnn
أنت